okay my first guest honored to have him
the former attorney general under
President Obama who's now chair of the
National Democratic redistricting
committee Eric Holder great to see you
mr. Attorney General
thanks for doing this thank you Bill
well so you know one of the problems I
find with the pandemic is that it's very
hard to have a conversation even with
anybody else with anybody about anything
else it's the only issue that people
talk about and I think we are losing
seconds in fact we're six months from an
election right which I know you are
trying to make sure comes out fair and
square is that what your committee is
all about or is it a fancy way of saying
gerrymandering well we want to try to
combat what happened in 2011 when the
Republicans really gerrymander to a
degree that we've not seen in recent
memory but we also focus on this
presidential election and the elections
more generally in November to try to
make sure that everybody who wants to
cast a ballot in November has the
ability to do so and can do so in a in a
safe way again our focus is on
gerrymandering but we don't want to just
fight for structures that we want to put
in place and then we have an election in
November that doesn't go well and that
will scuttle all of the work that we're
doing so we've really kind of broadened
what it is we are doing fighting for a
fair safe election in November as well
as concentrate and continue to
concentrate on our anti gerrymandering
efforts so you'd think there is a
scenario where that election does go
well because I don't I don't see any
scenario where it does because as I've
been saying for years now I don't think
Trump like I do not I cannot picture
that man gracefully conceding and
walking away and I keep asking Democrats
you're probably the one with the most
law enforcement experience I've ever
asked this what do you do if he says it
was rigged blah blah blah
it's not safe for me to let whatever
[ __ ] he's gonna come up with and
refuses to leave I want to know what the
plan is
well you don't I think he will certainly
say when he loses that it was rigged but
it was unfair he'll come up with all
kinds of reasons why he will cast doubt
on the legitimacy of the election
but and I'm really worried about what
happens between November is defeat and
when he actually leaves office in
January that I think is the period we
should be focused on he'll still have
presidential power and how god only
knows how he'll use it on the day of the
inauguration I actually think that he
will leave and if he doesn't leave the
United States Marshal Service the
Metropolitan Police Department here in
Washington DC Secret Service all have
the ability to pull him out of the White
House we'll get on with the inauguration
and the presidency of July they have the
ability
I know do they have the will I mean you
mentioned the police department police
love his dirty drawers you really think
they're gonna pull him out of the White
House yeah I mean I think you know it's
interesting because I think people in
law enforcement positions people with
the power to do those kinds of things
will really as I always say they'll
check to the power and the power will
move on the inauguration day and my
guess would be that all the people all
the organizations that have that
capacity will do the right thing the
constitutional thing and listen to the
orders of the of the new president and
understand that there has been again a
peaceful transition of power regardless
of what is that the Trump might want to
do
okay well color you more optimistic I
don't see him that took two months
you're describing between the election
and the inauguration day he's just gonna
be ranting and raving and his people are
gonna be in the streets and okay but
we'll move on so New York State
cancelled their primary 16 states have
postponed them this is rather
unprecedented I wonder if you think this
is a dangerous precedent we Americans
have voted through everything Civil War
Spanish flu depression canceling an
election I think is a well what do you
think well I think postponing these
elections makes sense to do them at a
time when people are less vulnerable to
the pandemic coming up with alternative
ways that people can cast a ballot so we
don't have a repeat what we had in
Wisconsin when people had to stand in
line for extended periods of time to
cast a vote and we know now that in
Wisconsin at least 30 people
have come down with the virus that can
be directly traced to their having to
stand in line I'm sure that number is it
is gonna grow but canceling that's not
something that I think we ought to do
now I understand that what happened in
New York was they just simply cancelled
the primary with regard that the
presidential primary there with the
result we already know what it is but
the rest of what is supposed to occur on
primary day in New York is I understand
it gonna continue go on so I would be
not in favor of canceling things but I
do understand how there might be the
need to postpone and then put in place
alternative means so that people can
vote safely
you